president biden and democrats democrats
excuse me ramping up their rage at the
supreme court after a bombshell leak
indicated that the high court is ready
to strike down roe vs wade protesters
taking to the streets in major liberal
cities chanting we won't go back some
clashing with the lapd police say a
group there threw rocks and bottles at
the officers and one cop was injured top
democrats echoing the fury coming from
the base
i am angry
[Music]
an extremist
united states supreme court
thinks that they can impose
their extremist views on all of the
women of this country and they are wrong
how dare they
how dare they try to stop her from
determining her own future
how dare they
try to deny women
their rights
and their freedoms
president biden adding fuel to the fire
earlier and lobbying some serious
attacks at republicans
this is about a lot more than abortion
what happens if you have a state change
the law saying that that that children
who are lgbtq can't be in classrooms
with other children
is that is that legit under the way the
decision is written
what are the next things that are going
to be attacked
because this mega crowd is really the
most extreme political organization
that's existed in american history judge
i do want to start with that because
there's also this this idea that the
left is pushing less than 24 hours after
this leak that the uh supreme court next
they're going to ban interracial
marriage which would be very strange for
clarence thomas to do i have to say yeah
i i agree with that look you know
according to joe biden and the dems the
sky is falling i mean this is like the
for them the worst thing if they can
predict anything will happen they will
use this as a reason to fire up the base
because they have nothing going for them
in the midterms but make no mistake
griswold versus connecticut loving
versus virginia all those other cases
alito was very clear in the decision
quote we emphasize that our decision
concerns the constitutional right to
abortion and no other right nothing in
this opinion should be understood to
cast out on other precedents that do not
concern abortion he makes it specific
this is about abortion and in addition
some of those other
rights are based on equal protection
civil rights not necessarily on the
right to privacy so that should all be
removed from the discussion of this case
rob we haven't had a chance to hear from
you on this on this show on this week
let's give you the floor i think that
first of all republicans make a mistake
when they emphasize the crime
of uh of the leak itself
over the impact of what the decision
would entail
for the women and i think that emotion
however you think of those particular
personalities that is that is legit this
is uh uh
more problematic i think and judge i
think you'd agree with me what this
shows because it goes both ways what
this shows is that the senate
confirmation process by which a nominee
is interrogated by both parties and give
give their reasons why they are fit to
be on the high court
is absolutely deeply flawed why because
these nominees lie
they go before the senate of the united
states they up they swear that they're
going to be
judicious and good uh
you know shepherds of the of the court
and its impartiality and the importance
it
has in american society and that the
starry decisis that the precedent of
these cases well established
30 years 40 years 49 years that that is
uh something that the supreme court
honors and then they turn around the
minute they get in the high court they
make a decision that is so dramatically
opposed to what they said during the
confirmation hearings shame on them
shame on gorsuch shame on coney barrett
shame on kavanaugh they knew when they
were swearing to those senators or in
the conversations in the senate offices
that they were going to vote to reverse
or overthrow roe v wade they knew it and
they lied about it and i i don't know
how you fixed that
i don't know how you can repair when the
the most
sacred
office in the land the high court of the
united states
is peopled by
politicians you know if i was accused of
being a serial rapist because i like
beer at 16 i'd probably say whatever i
needed to to get the hell out of that
building
you said that i would agree with you i
absolutely do not agree with you there
was no lying to the to the senate uh on
to that judiciary committee because they
talked about starry decisis starry
decisis means that you follow precedent
they were clear to say this is not one
of the super uh
uh uh due process cases like board
versus uh brown versus board of
education that overturned plessy versus
ferguson separate but equal okay they
were very clear especially amy coney
barrett she was very clear to say starry
decisis means that the courts under us
have to respect our decision as the
supreme court the highest court in the
land and unless it's super due process
unless it's like brown versus board of
education where you cannot separate
white and black children then we can
decide based upon what comes before us
what we can i have not three daughters
in the state of ohio
is a fetal heartbeat law that will now
be immediately a different issue it will
now be the law of the state of ohio and
what am i going to tell my daughters now
that they don't have control over their
body that they can't make those choices
for themselves that some old man
scratching his belly in some other state
is going to say
it's not i mean tony barrett is not an
old man scratching her i want to play
that seven old men did the roe v wade
decision in case you forgot let's listen
to uh some media responses to all of
this if we could please
the founding fathers didn't recognize
abortion as a fundamental right because
the founding fathers were racist
misogynist jerk faces so that's the
history that sam alito is is is
accessing honestly at this point i think
we're all right to question the
legitimacy of the court no
will be a mass criminalization event so
don't think this is just a war on women
it could be a war on people of color
and gay people
what all right greg do you want to take
that one yeah i mean we were talking
about this i think before this show
yesterday or the break but this is why
pro-lifers win
because they can state their case so
plainly if you ask somebody why they're
pro-life they will say
because abortion takes a life and we
believe life is sacred you can disagree
with that but you can't disagree with
the simplicity of it right but the
problem with the pro-choicers is that
they don't have the balls to state their
case plainly just say like i prefer
freedom over fetuses don't sit here and
come up with all of these other things
like it's going to be interracial
marriage next my body my choice how much
simpler can you get let me finish you
already did your uh ad hominem um people
we were talking about this yeah you you
insulted a few people there um we talked
about this people are more concerned
about what they lose than what they will
gain because you don't have to imagine
loss all you got to do is talk to
somebody who lost a child
but you can't you it's it's it you don't
have to imagine it and it's there
forever
a pro-choice mom can look at her
adorable two-year-old and think my life
would be nothing without her in 2022. in
2017 when she was young and single
didn't have a kid she could only imagine
the loss of her freedom right so that's
the issue the issue here is that people
need to imagine right they can't step
back and see how pro-choice
or arguments are driven by refusal to
imagine what that baby could be
but then when that baby
bees then suddenly it changes right and
then they have to create reasons they
have to create all these reasons to be
pro-choice rather than just be honest
and say yeah it kills an unborn kid but
i prefer my freedom that's all you got
to say you get so much more respect the
other thing that drives me crazy now
that i'm on my soapbox is it used to be
even the pro-choicers would admit that
abortion
was an ugly thing but they felt it had
to be a necessary evil uh something that
would be safe and rare that was the
argument you always heard i went on
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now